freunde eine kurze anmerkung bevor das
video ist wirklich losgeht und zwar habe
ich beim aufnehmen den rahmen zu klein
gesetzt in openbroadcast abbas
aufgenommen werden soll das heißt ihr
habt die ganzen elemente die ganz nah am
rand sind habt ihr nicht mit drin aber
dass noch ein recht unnötig weil das
lose sachen sind wie wieviel vorteil ich
habe und ob ich das bei facebook teilen
will so ein paar sachen das heißt die
seht ihr heute nicht in den nächsten
videos von dem spiel oder allgemein vom
ipad werte wieder der rand und so was
alles die elemente dort mit aufgenommen
tut netze für diesen moment leid und
jetzt wünsche euch viel spaß beim
monster legend hallo ich meine liebe
freunde und herzlich willkommen hier zu
einer weiteren folge von dem laden
erstmals elfi in der aufnahme ruhe
ich habe mir gesagt so oder ich habe
halt zumindest euch gesagt dass ich das
spiel bisschen öfter machen werde ist
mir das glück glücksrad weil ich hier
gerade einmal 5000 goldscheuer versuch
wer aber genauer edelsteine kommt
freunde wir drehen hier nochmal ich
möchte dabei haben alter ich drehe so
lange bis ich irgendwie falsch eine
andere richtung freunde ja das könnte
sogar
ich möchte nur dass also ich hab mir
gesagt ja freunde ich habe lust mehr von
monster lädchen drachen beim entladen
hier gefällt deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht ich zock jetzt mal ich möchte
schnell also ok rich mal schneller gut
gedreht und ich habe das gefühl das ist
jetzt das ei das ist weder vom schon
bruder jetzt muss das altern seien schon
wieder nur ford alias etwa ist das
allerletzte mal drehen und wir haben
fred frith alfredo also manchmal kurz zu
sagen was ich jetzt überhaupt mache ich
habe mir vorgenommen für diese folge
dass ich ein bisschen mehr kämpfe dass
ich euch meinen stadt ein bisschen
zeigen weil ich ein ganz klein bisschen
weiter gespielt auf screen obwohl ich
das eigentlich nicht will ich möchte
euch aber so viel zeit wie möglich dass
auch bei minecraft leben mache und so
weiter was ist das denn
firefighter paket kaufen wir uns normal
verdächte ja okay jetzt haben uns das
gekauft und jetzt könnten wir mal 120
jede stelle für flying dragon paket kauf
nehme mal im free tv mesum und jetzt
gehe ich mal auf meine alter der bau
schon anders aus zu brüten hier haben
wieder ordentlich gold gesammelt so
sieht übrigens jetzt gerade meine meine
monster stadt aus ich habe ja alles
versucht ein bisschen hoch zu leveln
hier das habe ich ein bisschen ausgebaut
dass sie habe ich auch ein bisschen
ausgebaut ihr seht schon die monster
hier sind level 10 also niemand bad
gewehr und giebel und ruderer habe ich
mir auch gekauft also das habe ich mir
gekauft
ich hab den bauernhof ausgebaut und ich
habe auch ein paar neue ziele bekommen
die ich umsetzen muss und davon werden
wir doch jetzt erstmal er halte ein
ernster all diese elementare monster
gehört auf jeder insel homo uns noch mal
ein monsterblock kämpfe für 600 ziel
erreicht alter das ging schnell ok
kommen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen acht
da komme ich bekomme ich james für das
kommt mir noch recht gelegen
beschleunige das ausbrüten und schneller
monster zu erhalten
ja klar das kann ich doch eben schon
machen hier kriege ich einfach drauf
auch brüten jetzt fertig stellen ziel
erreicht wir haben einen kleinen affen
bauer einen neuen erde lebensraum aus
dem laden
am anfang muss aber echt sagen dieses
spiel erklärt mir zumindest alles bei
anderen spielen weil ich zu anfang
überfordert habe zum beispiel mega lange
braucht bis sich die steuerung von swing
pop das damals raus bekommt
wieso zeige ich die ganze zeit den
schaden mit meiner hand hängen also ich
finde echt das ganze wird die mega gut
erklärt also wenn ich mir jetzt monster
hole steht da sogar jahre mussten
lebensraum der erde bauern führt er mich
dazu zu den lebensräumen der erde dass
man nach und nach das spiel kennen lernt
das ist auf jeden fall sowieso ähnlich
wie bei fifa ultimate team finde ich
also bei fifa ultimate ihn ist es ja
auch so dass du alles von anfang an
erklärt bekommst und das finde ich
richtig geil zum beispiel auch ich würde
übrigens auch mal gerne wieder fifa
machen hätte dieser box mit ganz ganz
vielen kommentaren wenn die bock habt
dass man eine runde fifa mache aber
zusammengeschnitten also witzige szenen
dann nur hier wieder gold einsammeln und
dann packen wir jetzt mal das ausbrüten
platzieren in der erde und jetzt wo
alter als der gal rock ja jetzt schon
lily verknallt okay er heißt atrium wird
wird er jetzt einfach mal ab hunde haben
mega viel fressen weil ich da james
reingepackt habe neue fertigkeit
erlernen schwere knöchel-op stark jetzt
wie ich möchte jetzt hier kommen hier
pro kilo guckt euch den an bord der gail
kiri sich dieser typ ist erinnert mich
so ein bisschen an maroc finde ich alter
guckt euch mal an wie graziös der sich
fortbewegt alter der krabbel zu über den
boden gesagt dieser [ __ ] wenn ich
hier so hallo webfocus und grippe welche
so lander ökonomen und die webcam zu
kommen hier ja dann werden wir doch
jetzt mal übrigens mir ist aufgefallen
in letzter zeit konnte ich viel mehr um
die facetime herum und gibt hier so
umdrehen weg rum viele finden das
scheiße los mit dir du dich total
hyperaktiv
neuerdings aber ich weiß mir macht das
spaß zum beispiel der ersten folge
monster jetzt habe ich auch einfach
mittendrin angefangen staub zusammen ich
fand das auch so behindern wo ich in
einer folge einfach hinten stehe ich
werde übrigens bald nach köln ziehen ich
schon angekündigt ich bin zurzeit an
wohnungs schauen und bla ich komme mit
echtem er klar ich wohne direkt an der
bahn in hamburg das ist so laut um das
ist auch vor allem sodass ich
das hier immer diese penner sind um dann
hier vor der tür einfach saxophon
spielend die haben nicht mal talent ich
denke mir nur so ein behinderter affe
oder rock killer könnte besser die kacke
da spielen wenn ich keine belohnung
dafür wenn ich die bier und datum also
killer zusammen
süchte und ich will echt nicht wissen
was da herauskommt
das haben wir jetzt bekommen vorher jako
o mein brennender affe sieht so ein
bisschen aus wie evo lial sowie die deg
heißt eben ich glaube es heißt eboli
aber ich glaube die voll variante halt
noch mal als noch mal anders ist das
geil
wir haben ein was wir schon mal seine
entwicklung an
okay das schon recht frisch brennan
barock im alter junge dem pakt direkt
auf level 10 ihr alter das macht mir
richtig spaß kommen jetzt hier
wir füttern im einfach die ganze scheiße
wieder rein nein nein nicht teilen man
freunde hat jetzt steht oben übrigens
immer lukas ipad das ist immer wenn ich
aus versehen auf dieses facebook.com ich
werde dann zukunft nicht mehr drauf
kommen ich werde euch versprechen war
dennoch ein bisschen hier bisher noch
eine neue fertigkeit erlernt hat und
dann muss ich auch gleich mein ding star
ausbauen meine ich damit ich dir höher
als level 10 krieg ich habe übrigens die
so viel futter gekauft weil ich einfach
dachte die aufnahme kaufe ich mir mal
ein paar james die klare 20 euro darüber
dass und einfach weil das geht dann
schneller wald in der aufnahme ist er
trug das meine ich deine vor monstern
momentan bis maximal stufe 10 aufsteigen
errichtete den feuer tempel alter okay
dann kommen nur den feuer tempel ok
krass dann setzen wir den feuer tempel
einfach hier vor damit die alle denen
das steuern von akte x dahin okay jetzt
hab ich den feuer tempel
oder store wieder eine stunde jetzt
fertig stellen jetzt auf dem feuer
tempel und jetzt komme ich kann ich kg
höher machen ich muss noch erde monster
tempel bauen ein ding führen gegen
freunde dann kommt ihr natürlich auch
der tempel hin sagt fertigstellen und
jetzt machen wir kg shui ruine gleich
werden so was von viele gegner reguliert
ok ich glaube ich dass man gegen
kopfmassage aus das habe ich übrigens
bei pokemon auch mal so gemacht dass ich
nie bei einer feier beim feuer pokémon
beispielsweise hatte ich nur feiertag
mein wasser pokémon wasser attacken weil
ich fand das scheiße wenn die dann auf
einmal so normal attacken können ich
hasse diese normale attacken aber egal
wir fangen jetzt mal eben anzukämpfen
und zwar mehr spieler okay ich kenne
jetzt gegen so einen typen aber ich
glaube ich bin sogar besser aufgestellt
als der aber keine attacke von mir ist
wirklich stark
ich mache jetzt mal einfach sprung
schlag auf den hier
das ist schon stark aber es ist nicht so
verhältnismäßig stark dass daran gezeigt
wird herrscht auf dem machen da
schmeckte guckt das schwache umfeld du
bist tot und scheiß electronic alter
brennender ball ist schlecht wenn ich
das auf dem feuer pokémon mache ich lag
schon buchen und bei monster dass das
verstehe ich jetzt endlich gesagt nicht
dass das feuer da jetzt nicht so viel
bringen wenn ich das offen offen auf dem
blatt pokémon machen kritiker schätzt
auch noch den letzten schliff auch in
ordnung mit video vermittelt und
brennender wahl war - noch hinsichtlich
ready für letzten attacke
bilder heep und ok krass oder wie viel
kommt kann ich deine sachen will ich
möchte auf jeden fall das rote bitte gut
gedreht komm komm ich weiß zwar nicht
was das rote ist aber sieht richtig cool
aus und ich habe das blaue was ist das
ausdauer stufe eins was bringt mir
drehen
je schneller ich hab doch dort eine
wasser ist wichtig deswegen wird
so freunde da ich das nächste mal
wahrscheinlich erst wieder ein paar
tagen aufnehmen
hole ich mir jetzt ebenso ein zwei tage
schild dass ich da nicht irgendwie
angegriffen werde oder so und da
irgendwas verliere das kenne ich noch
von clash of fans damals
dann sammelt hier noch schnell eben die
sachen hier ein ziel können wir das
nächste mal noch ein bisschen weiter
machen in der nächsten folge werden wir
dann online eventuell auch ein bisschen
weiter größere kämpfe dann machen ich
werde in der zwischenzeit wieder so ein
paar monster hier trainieren wenn ihr
bock hatte dass ich schneller
aufgenommen habe und wenn ihr bock hab
das noch 23 mehr videos davon mache
zeigt es mir unbedingt mit einer
bewertung und schreibt mir die
kommentare fifa volt und eventuell noch
mehr tipps hat für das spiel
das wird nicht mega freuen ich hoffe
euch gefällt diese kleine kurze serie
ich möchte kein komplettes netzwerk
ausmachen sondern nur so 5 6 folgen bis
das spiel mir selber vielleicht nicht so
viel spaß macht obwohl es ist ja echt
spaß macht und ich finds mega cool dass
man einfach monster nehmen kann kann
steht zu seinem partner rasch neues
monster
damit verabschiede ich mich für euch von
fordern euch für heute und wir sehen uns
in einem nächsten video wieder ciao
freunde bis jetzt hat noch mal im
schnitt aufgefallen was ich halt euch
auch schon am anfang des videos gesagt
habe dass dann hat elemente verdeckt
wurden allerdings wurden so viele
elemente verdeckt war fand ich echt
nicht gedacht also am rand fahren doch
ein paar wichtige elemente wie
beispielsweise welcher tag nicht allen
sätzen wie viel schaden die machen wie
viel geld ich teilweise gewonnen hat wie
viele sachen nicht angebaut habe und
soll es tut mir wirklich extrem hat dass
dort viele elemente wirklich nicht
angezeigt wurden
ich weiß nicht woran es lag ich habe es
genau so bearbeiteten eigentlich auch
den rahmen genauso gemacht wie sonst
auch immer schaffe das ganze hätte ich
jetzt nicht wesentlich dabei gestört
dieses video anzuschauen ab den nächsten
folgen sicher besser